fabrice di vizio merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors le
tribunal administratif de strasbourg
estime donc que l'obligation de porter
un masque partout et tout le temps
constitue une atteinte à la liberté
d'aller et venir selon vous le port du
masque est il effectivement une atteinte
à la liberté personnelle
la tribune elle le dit en tout cas je
suis j'ai moins de qualités que le
tribunal pour le dire s'il tribunes
elles le disent c'est qu'on peut le
croire
en tout cas ce que je sais c'est que
incontestablement nous avons un problème
avec le port du masque je vous rappelle
quand même que j'ai saisi l'ensemble des
tribunaux administratifs de france
contre tous les arrêtés préfectoraux qui
impose le port générale et obligatoire
du masque à l'extérieur parce que
précisément sur quels éléments
juridiques sûr qu'elle arrive à gérer
dit justement et bien précisément parce
que c'est disproportionné précisément
parce que savait pas pour des motifs de
santé publique
précisément parce que le haut conseil de
santé publique a dit que le masque à
l'extérieur et bien effectivement
n'était pas justifié ce dans des cas
particuliers qu'aux fonds skalli le
tribunal administratif de strasbourg
guerre est ce qu'on sait depuis des
semaines
est ce qu'on sait depuis des mois
maintenant et le port du masque à
l'extérieur n'est pas une décision
scientifique
c'est une décision politique et qui
vient effectivement faire de la
surenchère politique rien d'autre
justement avec le collectif ces 19 d'un
côté vous avez saisi le conseil d'état
le 13 juillet pour rendre le port du
masque obligatoire à l'intérieur de
l'autre vous vous battez pour qu'il ne
soit pas obligatoire à l'extérieur
pourquoi au fond ce positionnement
pourquoi pas de masque partout tout le
temps
et bien parce que les uns font de la
santé et l'autre près du droit et que le
droit et la santé s'accommode mal du
général tout le temps le droit et la
santé sont ainsi fait que on prend en
compte les situations particulières au
moment où elle se présente et on évite
généralité
absurde qui viennent effectivement
ensuite un cas qui viennent donner un
sentiment de dégoût de la part de tout
le monde et qui vient faire qu'on
n'arrive plus à rien respecter la vérité
est simple le port du masque à
l'intérieur se justifie y compris sur
les plateaux télé au passage est
effectivement à l'extérieur eh bien ça
n'a aucun fondement scientifique
au fond c'est très simple alors il a
également à la question du port du
masque en entreprise obligatoire mais
avec des dérogations
quelle est votre position sur le sujet
vous rejoignez le bon sens en fondant la
mise en avant par le ministère du
travail alors je vais vous dire quelque
chose
le mot bon sens dans cette épidémie il
faut définitivement oublié cette
expression l'expression bon sens il faut
la radier il faut la rayer de plus
jamais l'empoigné parce que s'il ya une
chose que cette épidémie nous a
définitivement enlevé avec une part de
liberté
c'est effectivement le bon sens non je
ne partage pas l'avis du ministère du
travail
le protocole sanitaire je vous rappelle
qui a été publié trois jours n'a aucune
valeur obligatoire
c'est un fourre tout absolument
indescriptible et nous avons un
gouvernement d' irresponsables qui
cherche à faire peser aujourd'hui le
risque du virus sur les employeurs et
certainement pas en assumer la
responsabilité du maine alors comment
comprenez vous tous ses ordres et contre
ordres des autorités sur le port du
masque on se souvient il ya encore
quelques mois
le masque ne servait à rien aujourd'hui
il faut pas le porter à l'extérieur à
l'intérieur comment vous comprenez tous
ses ordres et contrat aurait contrôle
alors d'abord il faut vous souvenir d'un
mots que j'emploie depuis le premier
jour c'est le mot grand guignol nous
avons à faire et ça se confirme
puissamment à un gouvernement de
branquignols le retard que nous avons
pris sur l'épidémie ne se rattrapera
jamais il aurait fallu au moment du des
confirmands avoir une vraie politique de
santé publique
avoir une vraie politique en amour
agressive sur la crise c'est à dire
effectivement avoir une réflexion de
fond nous n'avons rien fait aujourd'hui
ce gouvernement est perdue liste un
gouvernement d'incapables et
d'incompétents qui prend des mesures des
contre-mesures des et des actions et des
dérogations
plus personne n'y comprend rien et je
vais vous dire je pense que lui même n'y
comprend plus rien je pense qu'au sein
du gouvernement
les différents ministres ne comprennent
plus rien les administrations ne
comprends plus rien on a un directeur
général de la santé qui est parti chez
paou viable il a disparu
nous n'avons plus de capitaine à bord du
navire plus rien et donc ça donne ce que
nous vivons actuellement
comme vous le dites désordre des
contrôles nous avons un gouvernement qui
est perdu et pour conclure qu est ce qu
il aurait fallu mettre en place à la
sortie du confinement
déjà il aurait fallu essayer de
réfléchir c'est je sais c'est compliqué
dans ce pays mais si on avait commencé
par réfléchir je vous assure qu
effectivement ça aurait été beaucoup
mieux
moi j'ai vécu et je continue de vivre à
temps partiel dans un pays qui avait
choisi au sortir du confinement de dire
on va imposer des mesures importantes
drastique et qu'on va relâcher au fur et
à mesure en fonction de l'évolution de
l'épidémie en france on a fait le choix
inverse
on a dit aux gens on entendit le masque
sur les transports mais seulement vous
pouvez faire ce que vous voulez allez-y
d'avoir un à dix cents kilomètres à
prendre a dit faites ce que vous voulez
bien sûr partez en vacances c'est
important et pendant les vacances on
leur dit non alors attendez je vous
explique à l'intérieur vous portez pas
tout le temps le masque parce que ceci
parce que cela sur les plateaux télé ah
non il ya une dérogation peut-être etc
mais effectivement à l'extérieur
vous le portez tout le temps bon
effectivement ce qui aurait pas les
faire c'est avoir une cohérence globale
depuis le départ et s'adapter à la
progression du virus
je rappelle à dernier point le virus
effectivement tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire que ce que nous vivons
aujourd'hui n'est pas ce qu'on a vécu au
mois de mars et il faut pas confondre la
peur et la prudence
oui à la prudence non on a peur merci
beaucoup fabrice di vizio d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes l'avocat du collectif c 19